[Music]
thank you
marriage skipped the end who cares about
things like vows and Oaths and
everything else same man and whites you
know if your own immediate and
uninterrupted happiness is the focal
point of your marriage it will fail for
our daily cancellation today we must
cancel a woman named Kelsey ballerini
who I'm told is a country star I know
nothing about her music but I do know
everything I need to know about her
personally based on a conversation she
recently had during an episode of a
podcast called tell me about it with
Jade Iovine now the brief clip of this
exchange which we will play for you now
could be an extremely valuable tool
especially for young couples young
people in dating relationships they ask
me all the time how they can know if
they've selected the right partner for
marriage right that's the big question
well here's one way this is a good
litmus test sit your girlfriend down or
your boyfriend down play the following
clip for them and then ask if they agree
with the attitudes and perspectives they
hear in it and if the answer is anything
but oh hell no are you kidding me run
don't walk run in the other direction
and never look back
so with that setup here it is
[Music]
anxiety or negative intrusive voices in
your head and that it was actually like
your heart speaking that's a good
question I'm really like intuitive and
in tune with myself and like my gut and
my heart the glitter wears off that's
what happens you know and then you just
you get into a phase where you just you
wait for it to come back you know and
then sometimes it doesn't it is such a
disservice and a dishonoring of yourself
if you know something is not right and
you stay I think when people hear about
couples counseling than they hear about
a couple getting divorced they're like
oh it didn't work but oftentimes that is
actually couples counseling working and
I think what's so hard is having to
break your own heart and someone else's
in the process of saving yourself okay
so the glitter wore off after five years
and then Kelsey patient woman that she
is waited around for hours maybe even
days potentially a week waiting to see
if the magical marriage glitter would
fall from the sky but it didn't and she
doesn't want to be in a non-glittery
marriage who would uh indeed she says
that it would be dishonoring and a
disservice to herself
if she were to honor her marriage vows
and remain loyal to the man that she
pledged her undying love and devotion
too
but who cares about things like vows and
Oaths and everything else I mean think
about the glitter that's what matters
so she got up and left now here's the
issue with um the marital insights
offered by Kelsey and Jade what we heard
In that clip is is the very common and
very wrong uh passive view of marriage
and romance it's the idea
that your relationship with your spouse
is fueled by some sort of mysterious
emotional Force which is often
incorrectly called love and that as soon
as your marriage runs out of this
mystical fuel all you can do is abandon
it on the side of the road and hitch a
ride to the next card that happens to
drive by this view is popular in our
society because it removes all
responsibility and all blame from the
individual love is something that you
fall into right and there's not much you
can really do the cause to cause the one
to prevent the other
we chalk it up to irreconcilable
differences it's all just stuff that
happens oops I'm married oops I'm having
an affair oops I'm divorced oops I'm
married again oops I'm divorced again
oops I'm lonely and isolated and
everyone I've ever known resents me oops
silly me I'm so clumsy
here's the reality these were choices
every step of the way and the state
which you find yourself in
falling in and out of this is not love
because Real Love is an act of will it's
a decision it's a conscious activity
it's something that you do it's
something that you live
okay love is chosen
and if it's protected and nurtured it
grows love is sacrifice love is effort
Love is Everything Saint Paul describes
in First Corinthians love is dying to
yourself love is is many things and none
of them happen by accident but most of
all it's a thing you do it is an
activity so Kelsey when she talks about
the glitter
what she's really describing is the
infatuation phase but it's all she ever
had with her husband and once it died
rather than work towards a truly loving
and self-sacrificial marriage she just
bailed
of course the other problem with this
approach aside from the fundamental
misunderstanding about the nature and
meaning of Love is that it's entirely
self-centered if you know if your own
immediate and uninterrupted happiness is
the focal point of your marriage it will
fail if the only thing you care about is
your own happiness you will never do
anything worthwhile in your life you
will be a failure you'll be a miserable
failure for your entire life you will
live a pathetic meaningless life and you
will die and nobody will believe and
remember that you existed if you live
entirely pursuing your own happiness and
nothingness okay it's not your spouse's
job to make you happy every second of
the day there is no one on this Earth
who exists
scratch up there is no one who who
exists in the entire universe and whose
only job is to make you happy that
doesn't that's that doesn't exist
anywhere and so it's not fair to put
that burden on your spouse especially
since the sort of people who expect
others to make them happy all the time
are also the sorts of people who are
never happy which means that you have
given your spouse a literally impossible
job that you will then blame them for
failing to accomplish and if it was just
Kelsey ballerini who had these uh
misconceptions about marriage it
wouldn't even be worth addressing but
tragically these misconceptions are
shared by many in our culture and it's
why so many marriages fail and uh and so
many others never even begin
and that's why it's still worth saying
today unfortunately Kelsey ballerini is
canceled you know a company's looking
out for you when they actually upgrade
your service and they don't charge you
for it pure talk just added data to
every new and existing plan they're also
including a mobile hotspot with each new
plan as well with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but you haven't made the
switch you need to take a look again for
just twenty dollars a month you'll get
unlimited talk text and now 50 more 5G
data plus a mobile hotspot I love pure
talk not only do they offer great
services but they also happen to be
veteran owned and they only hire the
best United States based customer
service team available remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you when you go to
puretalk.com Walsh you'll save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that's
puretalk.com Walsh puretalk Wireless for
Americans by Americans Gisele Bundchen a
supermodel and ex-wife of Tom Brady is
now speaking out publicly about her
divorce from the former NFL Stars
celebrities are very often shallow
self-absorbed and stupid and never does
that become more apparent than when they
are trying to publicly rationalize their
failed marriages Fox News has the story
quote Brazilian supermodel Gisele
Bundchen is breaking her Silence about
their divorce from former NFL superstar
Tom Brady the 42 year old model said the
split was the death of my dream as she
lost who was meant to be her partner for
life she lost him oh she lost him did
she did she what did she let go of his
hand at the mall did he wander off in
the middle of the night lost him no she
didn't she didn't lose him like you lose
a pair you know a pair of shoes she
chose to leave him as an active decision
I'm not sure to what extent it was a
mutual decision maybe it was maybe it
wasn't but it's certain at least that
she was an active participant in the
divorce she didn't lose anything she
gave up they gave up but don't tell her
that she likes to uh tell herself that
this has all happened on its own through
forces
outside of her control well it's tough
because you imagine your life was going
to be a certain way and you did
everything you could you know I believed
in fairy tales when I was a kid I think
it's beautiful to believe in that I'm so
grateful I did we wanted things together
as time goes by we realized that we just
wanted different things and now we have
to make a choice that doesn't mean you
don't love this person it just means
that in order for you to be authentic
and truly live that life that you want
to live you have to have someone who can
meet you in the middle right it's a
dance it's a balance when you love
someone you set them free to be who they
are and if you want to fly in the same
direction then that's amazing
okay let's clear up two things first
um if you leave your spouse
it absolutely does mean that you don't
love him the way that Giselle defines
love the way that our culture defines it
generally is essentially like this a
loving action is whatever action I
happen to be taking at this moment to
love someone is to do whatever I want to
do and this is what she means when she
says the word love you keep using the
heart I don't think it means what you
think it means love is not merely a
feeling and even if it was merely a
feeling you clearly don't feel too great
about somebody if you want to divorce
them a faithful marriage
and a divorce are both choices they are
they are options actively chosen Giselle
talks about marriage using passive
language we grow apart time goes by
sometimes you end up and you know you
end up going in different directions
it's like Tom and Gisele were two pieces
of litter you know a couple of empty
plastic bottles floating in a puddle
randomly bumping into each other and
then drifting off in opposite directions
now in any other situation she is
certain to speak highly and confidently
of her own her own agency her strength
as a Fierce and independent woman when
it comes to making excuses for a failed
marriage
suddenly she's a helpless flower being
swept Along by the forces of Fate second
uh Giselle claims that her divorce was a
necessary step in the pursuit of
authenticity now how would you detect
your own inauthenticity or your own
incongruence
well she says that in order to be
authentic and to live the life you want
to live sometimes you have to break your
marriage vows and destroy your family
oops but this is not authenticity not in
any meaningful way if it is authentic
it's only because you are authentically
following your most cowardly and
self-serving and shallowest impulses but
there is a higher authenticity right
there is an authenticity that we should
actually strive towards
and that is the authentic authenticity
of a virtuous life the authenticity of
faithfulness and love and sacrifice the
authenticity of Promises Kept and vows
upheld true authenticity can be found in
the pursuit of something greater than
yourself which is what marriage is all
about or what it's supposed to be
and that's what Giselle has abandoned
and that's why she is today finally
canceled that may be the first time in
my life a man is dead insult me
it won't be the last
[Applause]
foreign